You
Hello I don't know I'm holding this but I am let's pretend it's you how do I there we go
Hello, yes, we are nice and cozy. I have a cozy fear next to me
Hello, hi my day, how did my day go it's alright a lot of adulting adulting's dumb
Adulting is stupid
Go armpit for free it seems so
We're cozy today
We're gonna be playing some sucker for love, which has been super
Little popular semi-popular indie game
How are you you date
Eldritch gods and beings and this one you date
Some sort of a cult being
Which is very on theme for my summer ween
That summer ween
Get it. Um
But yeah
So yeah, we got to get those smooches. I've never played this before again
I'm the type of person who I just watch other people play things and I never play things for myself
Yeah, the first one I remember watching was really good I've seen
The demo of this but I haven't seen the full game and I know I think this is the full release
But yeah, I'm very excited to do it's very it's also on theme because it's a Zora's birthday this week. Yeah
So um, it's I'm very excited for a Zora's birthday
I'm excited to spend time with her and the girlies this weekend
With a little little collab
But yeah, this is this is an homage to a Zora in a kind of way
It just actually kind of really fit with the theme and also with her. So yeah, so make sure
When is there a streams you go check her out her link is my description below give her lots of love
But yeah, we call there being goat themed eldritch monster. This could be her again. I don't recall
I really like the design of her as we'll get into it. I've seen her design already
But yeah, I
Might be a little bit low energy today. I'm kind of tired. I'm also just kind of frustrated from adulting and silly stuff
But yeah, I just want to be honest and transparent with you guys
I'll be doing a little bit of voice acting today. I'll try to voice act all the characters to the best of my ability
I don't know if I can give her a Zora's voice
I I I just I have to like
Have a Zora speaking in my ear then I have to repeat after her for me to do the voice
But um, we'll we'll see
But yeah
Hopefully my day picks up. Thank you. I appreciate that
Boomi is currently behind me playing with this favorite toy, which is one of those spring toys
He is walking around with it in his mouth as we speak
He already knocked two onto the fridge that I gave him today, so I will have to retrieve those there's probably like 20 under there
Fia is napping. She just ate I gave her a piece of I was just eating a salmon rice bowl
During my waiting screen that I just made
So I gave her a little piece of salmon
With no with no seasoning or anything on it so she could have a little sneaky snack and she liked it. Hi Nori. Hi
Hello, everybody say hi to Nori Nori is my baby girl
She is one of my daughters her and Chai are my daughters if you haven't known
But yes and the more
But yeah, so
Yeah, I don't know I'm kind of kind of like I'm also I'll be honest with you
I'm also in a little bit of pain
From my fibro, so I'm just it's not like oh, I'm dying. Oh, it's so terrible flare up
Oh, it's just like I'm just feel sore for no reason though
All I've been doing is typing at a computer, so it doesn't make any sense, but you know, that's how life works
Cats love salmon. Yes. I always I could give Fia a little minnow
I think did I give her a minnow on stream before I give her freeze-dried minnows because my cats are very spoiled
It's funny boomie has these phases where he really likes them and then he doesn't like them
I'm like does it depend on who packaged it or all that I
Was gonna make a joke about you being a pain because I did
Thank you, Nori. No yet
I have this like weird pain going down from my shoulders to my elbows to my wrists again
It's all like joint related stuff
But I'll be fine. Don't worry about it. It'll go away. I just need to like I'll do some stretches
I've done some stretching already, you know, I just I just you know, it might hear me
Rattle my bones and crack my neck and crack a bunch of stuff
Yeah, I'm gonna I need to do some I don't know. Maybe I'll do something at home yoga or whatever. I
Feel like something's out of place to be honest with you. Like I feel like I need to like pop something
Oh, or I just have like bursa. I like I like bursitis in my shoulder. It's weird
Hello, hi
Hi, if you're new here, my name is she be caught in mom
I am the girl failure Dom of the allures gen one in Dolce and I hope you will stick around
I love to do wacky voices. I like to be entertaining and be a little crazy
Amen, Hannah, you guys can't see me, but I'm shaking my body furiously
I just had to turn down the physics so my head doesn't fly off. I realize my head doesn't quite match my body
What's up with that? I don't know it doesn't matter
I'm a little insane in the membrane insane in the brain if you will
but
Yeah, we'll just we'll just we're just chilling. It's because you're autistic, you know, you're probably correct. I
Was reading through the posts I made last night on my all about me
This like having like stuff with control and how I need to have things just straight
So like I have a type of OCD
Well, I have normal OCD and then I have OCP D
But I just usually just over use like OCD because people know what OCD is OCP D is is a obsessive-compulsive personality disorder
And it's where you like have like an obsession with control and things being perfect like you're like a
Perfectionist to the like t-inth degree and so I was reading back and I'm like
Wow, I sound so autistic
I know I'm not like I
Think I was evaluated, but like it's just funny because like I have a lot of I
Have a flaw that like it but like I don't I don't like to say I'm something or like I am like
Because I don't want it to make it a person part like part of my personality like I'm some quirky manic pixie dream girl
It's just more like I'm being transparent and like this is my thought process guys is what I'm thinking about
It's usually due to these things. Let me tell you about it. And that's kind of why I bring stuff up
But yeah, it's okay. I'll do it for you. Nori is autistic in the best way. Not that there's a bad way, but
She's she's great. It's it's actually to be honest with you
You'd be surprised how many neurodivergent people are in the V2 being community and it's pretty like all these creative types coming together
It's really awesome to be honest with you
So yeah, it's pretty nifty I get to share share share a space with such cool people
You're quirky and that's okay
I'm literally so quirky
No, it's super interesting to read got me thinking about my own journey
Oh, yeah, like I always like to introduce like if people don't know so I might all yesterday
I talked about how like I have this like I kind of already just said it
But like how I had this need to control about what other people feel about me
But it's weird like as a viewer or if you like send me hay or if you're just like over like a no
You know a viewer. I love you to death blah blah blah blah
That's great and all but if it's like a peer of mine not that like not and I not one of my gen mates mind you
I'm more of like
People in the V2 being community as a whole that are also fellow vTubers big and small if someone
like
Doesn't respond or doesn't do something or doesn't do so certain way that like I have already in my head put together
I'm just like
This isn't perfect. This isn't what I wanted and so I was just like why do I have this obsession for everything to be liked and to
Kind of have everything a certain way and then I'm like, oh wait, it's mental Illinois
But yeah, so I like to have like it's always important to have some like self-reflection and introspection and stuff
I'm so sorry for starting the stream off like this. This is not how I wanted to start stream. I'll be honest with you
me just talking about stuff, uh
I'm so I feel like really like awfully Lee
Like I just feel silly silly Willie like I don't even know
Whatever I'll probably
Cut that out of the vaude because it's I'm very self-conscious about what comes out of my mouth
Although stuff is on the internet forever, so um, I
Just feel like it ruins like
Like I feel like it ruins the mood
Like I like we're here to have a date. We're here to like do stuff. We're here to congratulate
Is there for her birthday? We're here to I don't want to talk about that stuff. Oh, thank you
So for me for the 20 gifted, please say thank you if you got a gifted
I know you're invested in me, but I don't know. I'm just it's not it's it's not his birthday today. It's later this week
But yes, I thank you everybody who got one who got slapped with one
Excuse me. Hi. Hello. Hi there. Welcome in. Welcome in. Thank you so much. No kidding me
Saturday correct the moon wait
Do I have to look at my own gen mates birthday cuz I hold on I
Think it's Thursday, but we're doing it on Saturday
Because that was an easier time for her
Hold on. I'm pulling up in my schedule. Yes. I'm very bright all of a sudden
I
Where
Birthday is tomorrow
It's National Goat Day tomorrow. Maybe I should have played this yes to yesterday tomorrow
And then we have her her birthday don't a phone is on the 24th. So make sure you guys um
Take a peek over at her channel
Oh
Play goat simulator. No, I already made my schedule for the week. I'm doing I'm gonna go get my nails done tomorrow
and
I want to yeah, I just want to get my nails done like witchy I was good
I'll probably I don't know if there's a spirit Halloween or spirit. Hold on. There's spirit Halloween
Why is it casting hold on why is it casting my web page? What is
This
I don't it's saying that my
Mind that my window is being streamed, and I'm just like is it is it being streamed
What's going on here
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna close it so I don't accidentally do something stupid
Let me look it up on my phone instead
Cuz I remember one time I did something stupid where I googled something like what's the weather today, and then I pulled up
Who I was it wasn't that was in my PL though. Um
Spirit Halloween
Hello
Oh perfect
Cuz I want to get like a witchy like
Hand stuff. I put it on throne, but I don't think it was gonna come in time. So I took it off if anybody
Was gonna get it. I feel like I was gonna miss the the stream. Oh wait now. I can't see you guys
If she's wait
What hold on what's the what's the what are people saying in the chat is it like is it is
Where's the chat is it stuck it's always stuck. I
Just want to make sure it's just stuck
It's
Tap always be be being stuck. Um, all right, let me
Pull those back up again so I can see what you guys are shy in
Smell what you guys are cooking
Oh
My god, why can't I make stuff smaller? It won't make me let me shrink the window. Okay, there we go
Yippie
Yeah, dream about me
Was it a night dream?
We see me can you dream with me?
Yeah, let me get rid of this put this on
I
Can't hear anything
Can hear that that's for sure
No, you filthy freaky sweet appear. I'm like your panties. I'm not wearing any huh take that
I mean what? Okay, there's
I'm gonna take off the white way is it fully voice-acted or is it only a little bit voice-acted hold on
Is sucker for love
A date to die for fully voice-acted
Okay
Okay, so I will in the take off although I know the voice acting is very this is gorgeous by the way
This little one before jump scares. There's jump scares. Is this a horror game?
What
Jack over the desk and sniff
Why did I just get disconnected from my wife?
Oh, I'm gonna keep I'm gonna do the voices
Hey, look, it's I
I forgot the protagonist is tan. That's pretty cool
Whoa
I don't know if I'm gonna like play this to like all the endings are completion
At least in one episode. I love the art style
very very nineties
Oh
Chapter one the thousand versus the one
Wait, hold on I need to put on my
Eldritch gods
cosmos
Things beyond I understand him to merely gaze upon their forms to abandon all hope
They are sequestered to the stars appearing only through challenging failure prone rituals and in honorable incantations
May turn the music down
That's some intense music
They're twisted fanatical followers require no such invitation to commit horrors beyond belief in this stand
It is then when the boogeyman lurking in the shadows is an obscure and perceptible shade
but a tangible madman
That the vague prognostications of the stars become empty threats before the an undeniable material
A simple hatchet in their hands
Did
Something scary happen
Huh, huh
Oh wait, hold on I should give her a different voice in the book you're reading. Did something scary happen?
You're as pale as a sheet
Oh, just a strange dream
I'm all right
Oh
Sorry, this might sound strange, but can you tell me where I am?
You're in my bookstore in the Sacramento. Are you lost?
Oh, no, I think I know where I am now. Thanks
Bleeding hearts are a lot more hardcore than I thought
I've been having odd dreams lately waking in strange places. No memory on how they got there
Started around the same I keep stumbling over some of my words. I apologize
Started around the same time folks began vanishing from my hometown
Sacramento not Sacramento. Sacramento
Despite the small size of this backwater town dozens have gone missing this past year
So many that the trains won't even stop here now
I should probably change the voice because this is my mommy voice. I'm gonna give that to the goat lady. So I'll
Worried locals say they've spotted angry spirits probably
No, I can't
Worried locals say they've spotted angry spirits prowling the woods
Animals with too many features watching outsiders can't shake the feeling of being watched by the townsfolk unblinking purple eyes
The Sacramento stair they call it
Um, have you made a selection? Did you find a book to your liking?
Oh, gosh, I'm sorry. Didn't mean to keep you here late on my account
No, no, it's fine. I'm glad that you enjoyed reading my books
But it's starting to get dark outside with all the disappearances lately. You better hurry home
Um, my family fled this place long ago when the disappearances started
But a letter imploring me to come visit appeared in my apartment earlier this week
Hey stardust mom's still pretty shaken up about everything. So I'm taking care of her at grand's place
If you come by for a visit, I know it's here right up and help her feel better. We miss you like crazy
This is definitely my father's handwriting and only my parents call me stardust
Impossible
Mom dad, I know you're not really waiting for me. You've been gone for over a year
But whoever sent this note obviously wants me to come poking around and I aim to find out why
Spooky
Can be roman stoned instead
um
So her parents have already passed away
And somebody's luring her with how they're that spoopy
There's something strange in sacramento the dreams the stare the spirits
It's all connected. I'm sure of it
Whatever darkness has settled in our neck of the woods. I'm putting a stop to it
mom
dad
I love you both so much
I'll get to the bottom of this
Thanks for letting me doze off. I promise I'll come back real soon
Thank you for stopping in take care
A warm glow of the bookstore fades by sorry
There's a mystery foot
The warm glow of the bookstore fades behind me as I step out into the dusk
Sacramento this should be my hometown, but it's become
Unrecognizable
House sound by the way sound is sound good. Is it is everything good?
Well gang
Okay, cool
The streets are overrun with the dense foliage and missing person posters that litter every surface
They call this the missing person lane now
desperate
Wow really creative name desperate searchers put up posters here before vanishing themselves
It's the only path left and it leads straight to my gram's house
But something feels off the familiar landmarks of my childhood are nowhere to be found
How they got unturned around
No, I've walked in a straight line yet. Nothing looks right
Oh, I accidentally skipped. I think my mouse is broken and it's double clicking
May maybe if I check the note for my parents for the address
A grocery receipt impossible. I just had their letter. I even kept my pockets empty so I wouldn't lose it
Wait
This receipt has the exact dimensions and folds as the letter
Could I have
Imagined the whole letter
Oh
Yeah
Spooky
No
Impossible I checked the back and then double check the front, but the receipt means just that
Something is very wrong. I have to get out have to run have to
Hey, ow. Are you like blind or something? Watch where you're going. Katsurama
I slammed right into somebody coming the other way
Oh, I'm sorry. Are you all right? I should have been more careful
Whoa, she's really pretty, but what on earth is this girl doing wandering around Sacramento at night?
I
The purple green is a great aesthetic
Don't touch me
Sorry, I didn't mean to smack into you like that. I know it's not an excuse, but I was just in a rush
Oh, yeah, I know you gotta go run off and steal my boyfriend, right? Yeah, it's whatever totally cool
Save your breath. I already know how this goes
Wait, huh?
What
Your boyfriend?
Yeah, you heard me my boyfriend buck is mine
Who the heck is buck? Where are all these accusations coming from?
I don't know anyone named buck
Huh really you don't know who buck is
You're not like from out of town. Are you?
The stair it's real. I turned my head down a briskly walk faster. She starts walking alongside me
Male mention what the buck
Hey, look at me
I can't let her see my eyes no matter what she'll notice. I don't have the Sacramento stair. What the heck is that?
You can tell me are you from here or what?
I live here
Oh, yeah, look at me really quick. Sorry. I forgot to turn the oh, yeah, look at me really quick
This is bad even if I make it home. She'll know where I live. What do I do?
Look at me
I freeze before I know it. I'm already staring straight at her
Hmm
Bucky, hi got another one Priya. I'm missing person Lane
I break into a mad dash running my heart is everything is a blur
My heart pounding in my ears can't tell what the sounds of whistle shouts an undefiled commotion coming from all sides
Panting and dizzy
I feel my body slowing down, but the image of my face on the next missing persons poster kicks my leg into action one more
There a clearing up ahead if I can break their line of sight. I might find a chance to hide
As I near the turnoff my exhaustion makes itself known
If this is a dead end
Or it's too dark to find my way
I won't have the energy to turn around and start running again
Rounding the corner I gasp it's Grema's house. Thank goodness. I dash up the path and burst through the door
I hold the door shut for what feels like forever as my pulse grows
The pounding footsteps pass by outside
I'm safe for now
Hey, what's
I may just be standing at the entrance, but I can already tell something feels off about my home
Like the warm familiar place I grew up in is long gone
I can't put my finger on it, but
This dread
Why do I feel like I need to sneak around my own home?
Is someone here?
Hello
Dies first in a horror movie. Is anyone there?
No response
Oh
What
butterfly
A butterfly caught in a web strange. I don't see a spider around wonder how long the poor thing's been trapped. Can I can I have it?
Oh
Yep, my mouse is definitely going at least like towards the corner of it, but if I go up higher, it's fine. Okay, so I look it's me
Is there a timer? I don't think no, there's no timer
There's only a close button over here
So it looks like we got like the kitchen dining room just like area living room upstairs
Love and then all the bedrooms and then a bathroom and a shower
Meetings, okay
I'm not gonna know any way around by the way
I hate this
I forgot this is kind of a horror game
Please am I gonna have to buy a new mouse? Oh, I have to pull and drag
Where am I?
Okay
What guys
Oh
Can I
What's over there, huh? Our family photos look off
None of them have me in it and my siblings their faces seem unfamiliar
What are those weird symbols doing over there? Are you gonna talk about the giant bucket of paint like I
There's a bucket of paint
Boomi you need to get out the way. Oh, I thought that was a person. It's just a pig. Excuse me boomi. Can you get down?
Thank you
I
Mean I mean, yeah welcome to red ketchup
Looks like the triplets toys have been mostly untouched ever since we left in a hurry. What went on here
What's going on?
What's happening? Oh, I I'll go back. Yep. My mouse is messed up. Um
In gawa oh
Cry crykey. Cripes. What a mess. This place has been turned upside down, but nothing is missing weird
Oh, okay. All right anything behind me
Oh, she's standing right behind me. Isn't she wait where am I already lost? Okay. I already lost where I was
I
Don't like this bros
I don't like this bro. What uh, am I gonna talk about the purple paint everywhere?
Wait, what the hell? Oh, okay. Where am I?
Okay, I'll go upstairs
All right
All right, wow very beautiful
Beautiful artwork. Am I not gonna say anything about that? All right, it's a bathroom. I don't really need to go there
I'm scared to look in the bathroom
I
Messy painters
Hello, is that my bedroom? There's this my bedroom. Wait, why don't I just look at the map?
Wait, do I have to keep going down the hallway?
But there's no
Is it my dumb probably oh my mouse is freaking out
Okay purple
This is my bed what this can't be my bedroom
Some creep plaster in my little brother's room with smutty posters
Whoever did this is gonna get a fist in their face
Uh, I don't think this is your house my dear a pale flower. It's beautiful beyond belief
Okay
Nifty there's so many so many beds in one single room though
Some creep
Okay, I guess it's
What the heck this is very disorder. Oh, okay
Oh beautiful just how I left it
My room what on earth happened here this occult nonsense has someone been living in my house
The candles are still lit whoever's responsible was just here, but who why?
Oh, I'm like why is the game freeze this because it mine either no title no author and it reeks of death and decay
With trembling fingers. I opened it to a random page
Why is the game lagging so hard when I click
See the black woods instructions on how to corrupt the soil of a forest by using remains of a goat in the beating heart of a human
The beating what?
I've read and reread the passage, but it's plain as black and white the beating heart of a human
I read again and again my disbelief washing away more and more each time
this
isn't a joke
bleeding
A bleeding heart
First the stare that only the locals have then the
Disappearances then the supernaturally overgrown woods and now this the truth dawns on me smiley face
Sacramento has been overrun by cultists
All those missing people my parents they haven't been spirited away by angry forest spirits
They've been abducted and I'm next wait. I thought my parents were oh, they were
Dead, okay, awkward. There must be a way to stop this. I flipped desperately through the books pulsating pages
How does that happen searching for anything that might help?
Summon the all mother a ritual to force the dark deity behind this madness to physically manifest before me
Binding her in a form that can't directly harm me
This is it
My chance to end this nightmare once and for all to face a sinister goddess behind
Sacramento's madness and put a stop to her evil
Whatever the cost for the sake of everyone who suffered and died. I have to try
I'll bind this all mother to a physical form and destroy her looks like I already have everything I need to try
All right, what do I need?
Rocks on selva oscura
Ooh, she's pretty hot already
This ritual will bind the black goat to a physical form that can't harm you
However, no contact with eldritch gods is completely safe to summon her do any of the following dowsony lit candles
Ensure there is an idol the black goat present somewhere in the room have a plant
Mr. With you while facing a tree of the blackwoods chant her name. Okay
um, well, that's
The idol of a goat
Um
I'm gonna grab the plant mister
I can spray the speaker with water
What?
How does that work?
I don't know how that happened
This feature is primarily including consideration of players you just like being hit on by older women elder tribominations
But it has other uses too
what
Wait, so like if somebody why would they play the game if they don't want to be hit on by an eldritch being
That doesn't make any sense. Okay. Well, I'm gonna
Douse these candles
Have a plant mister
Got that i'm facing tree of the blackwoods
Azura do lay azura do lay azura do lay
Hit him
Mortal you dare summon me again
Have your pathetic lives not been extended long enough by my gift. Have you lost not been sated must you continue to torment your goddess? So
My heart pounds as an immense towering figure
Mysterializes before me my head is splitting open. I can't think I can barely breathe with this weight crushing down on me
Well, it's not as I can't do Azura's voice. So I'm just gonna you know
Do you have any idea who I am I am Roxanne the black goat of the woods and you will row this day
Madness given form shredding my insanity with each second that it passes
It's evil
Ancient and endless
Peering into the deepest parts of me that it was never meant to be seen
You tread on dangerous ground little lamb know that each time you summon me
My wrath grows
I will make you rear each second of agony you have inflicted
Now choose your next words carefully
What more could you possibly want of me?
Speak
I have to banish her to send her back before there's nothing left of me
But the words I need won't come did I really think I could face a power like this?
Stupid stupid girl
With the last shreds of my will I cling to the thought of why I came why I dared this folly
I swallow bile and terror straighten my spine grab a candle from the floor and speak shakily
I'm here to stop you from hurting another soul. I'm sending you back to the darkness you crawled out of one way or another
Really
Um, yeah
Oh, thank goodness. I thought this nightmare would never end
Um, aren't you supposed to be like trying to stop me or something?
No, I'm into this get me out of here
My brow fur is as I stare at her orlessly. Isn't she supposed to want to you know
spread madness and whatnot
damn she is
Oh
Can we just look at her? She looks really tired though, but I'm kind of digging the eye bags in the mole. Oh my god
We're twinning
And oh look at those
Hungers she looks really comfy. I really like this like
first shawl
thing going on
In the giant like fluffy pool. I feel like mercy should get a hairstyle like this where it's all up and crazy like that
That'd be so cool
Are we furries now?
Fuck
Yeah, those eye bags those are Louis Vuitton bags you're confused
Well, yeah, you want to be exercised
Banished yes, I'm rooted to your planets. You can wait now. I actually like the
Other deep voice that I had not with the British accent
Yes, I'm rooted to your planets and cannot be removed without a human's aid
I don't understand you have so many followers
Followers that just tried to kill me. I might add
Can't they free you instead?
Things have gotten messy with my cultists
messy in a bad way
I mean
My followers have turned against me and are abusing me in my woods power to kill outsiders indiscriminately
Have pity on this old tired goat and banish me so I can't trouble humanity any longer
Please
Help me
I wrote my temple. This is tricky on one hand. I came here to banish her
This crop de forest is devouring this town who knows how much farther all spread if nothing is done
I'm gonna move you guys over here so I can see the chat a little bit better
Oh
I don't blame her if I live for thousands of years of exhaustive
Well, it's not that like it's more so that she's like tired of like being linked to earth
I think she's like I kind of wanted to go back to what I was doing man, you know
On the other hand, I have serious reservations about helping an eldritch to god to anything
All of those missing persons posters. She's responsible. She and her cult are pure evil
But for now we want the same thing
Her gone
All right, tell me how to do this do I just grab any old knife and
Your mortal weapons can harm me can harm me. No can harm me child
But they cannot stop me
But that book you carry it holds the key to my banishment
Perform the rituals in order until you arrive at the uprooting ritual
That one will banish me for good
First things first you will need a partner
I am a goddess of lust so many of your rituals will require you to be in the presence of your ideal mate
Your heart's desire
Perform the spawn partner ritual on the next page
Oh
Spawn partner
Light the ritual candles the color of flame does not matter. So please you a color you find comforting
Have your choice of an aromantic herb herb on your person pick a scent you find pleasant
Imagine your ideal partner if it exists and it'll appear free before you in a cloud of smoke
If it does not exist it will be created
Do not imagine something you can't put back chant blablabla blablabla blablabla, okay
Uh, let's let's light some candles
Oh the blue is kind of a moon yellow
Oh
The green's kind of cool too. Where's the red? There we go. We'll do it red match me
My two partners on the bottom right of the screen rosemary lavender or mint. Um
Lavender is my mom's favorite. So maybe I shouldn't pick that. I like mint
Rosemary just
Just smells like food to me. So I'm gonna do mint
Um, I was gonna do rosemary because it has like
Comforting stuff to me, but then I don't want to spawn my mom. Although I guess this lady is kind of like my mommy
Some of the mojito. I think you know, I think I might
All right, and imagining my ideal a partner
harem harem harem harem
Oh
Oh my oh wait, I can't explain
Go ahead
Harem you look different
Uh, I've got nothing what is wrong with my taste
That
There's no need to be bashful, especially after all that time you spent playing coy
In view of the circumstances, perhaps I will allow you to be my partner
Really and that's okay with you even though we just met
Well, am I ideal partner is Azura?
For responding. No
No, your honor. This is no matter what I picked. This is what I've what have happened
I feel like Azura should play this game. That'd be pretty awesome
Well, it's sudden and it'll be a long long time before I can ever trust a human
Again, but I'm not exactly the god of
Taking things slow
Besides I already have a thousand children. There's no harm in a thousand and one
Wait, what are we talking about?
What
What are we talking?
Huh
Emi
Taking me as your partner
I thought you were just talking about being my girlfriend
You drink water
You
Thought you thought the two definitions of partners that a fertility goddess was referring to the platonic meaning
There's three meanings of partners
What's the third cowboys
Cowboys
Uh
Oh, are you still joking around while standing so close to me you should be melting with desire
Being anywhere within a mile of me should amplify or lost a thousand fold. I like how our little eye comes out
Oh, that's what it is. It's just a little it's another eye. It's on an eye bag
It's kind of cool. It's a neat little thingy
Oh, that's an easy one a thousand times zero is zero
Wait, are you saying what I think you're saying? Yep
So I take it you haven't had children yet
Nope
And you you aren't with child now
No
You're going to die here and and there's nothing I can do to help
What I thought we were gonna try to get you out of here. You're just not gonna help me because I don't have kids
It's not that I won't it's that I can't
I'm in an entity of untapped cosmic potential and I want a big family
The biggest family possible
I want every living thing on earth to be a direct descendant of me or one of my followers
Those that best serve that goal receive a fraction of my power
The most devoted followers are bestowed with gifts like extended lifespans rapid healing
Physical enhancement and in some cases immortality and those followers are the ones looking for you
You on the other hand have closed yourself off to my dark influence and are mortal and vulnerable
No kids no powers
What if I don't want powers or kids no badans and what hold on
And what if I drain the life from your body and then used it to fertilize my wicked soil until something
That will give me grandchildren comes crawling out
I take an involuntary step backwards
Huh, I'm sorry you didn't deserve that. Are you all right?
I'm fine. Don't worry about me
I
Powers or not. Let's move on to the next ritual so you can get out of here. Okay. I know she JoJo posed on this so true
Holy moly that was freaking scary and hot
She's really taking this hard. I better go get the stuff for the next ritual
All right next ritual
We need meat from a living thing that died within the blackwoods check the meat rack in the dining room
Milk of the black gold goat store bought 2% is apparently fine too. It's in the fridge
Lastly a receptacle fill to the brim of the good life blood. They mean blood. Please use blood from now on. Sorry. Oh
Oh
Yes liquid life
I feel like this like they put this in because of the joke like they put sorry in because of the joke
Chant while always facing fire red candles. Okay, so I already
Okay, let's make those red. Oh, oh she she looks really cute
So these followers are kind of like jealous ex-boyfriends then you want nothing to do with them, but they won't let you leave
Actually, yes, that's precisely right. They're like my exes
And using the same metaphor if you try to date me then my exes will hack you to death with farm tools
What is this scott pilgrim? I have to fight your deadly evil exes your seven deadly evil. I don't figure remember
I guess that last part wasn't a metaphor
Maybe I should get back to the rituals then
That's probably a good idea
All right, can I not talk to her again? Oh
Let's go
Slowly turn
All right, where am I? Uh
Okay, so I need to turn around yep
And then I need to use this week. Nope. I went the wrong way
This might I'm making myself freaking dizzy
What where the heck is happening? Hold on
What
Oh
Hello
This is fun
Huh, that's odd because somebody only had one futon downstairs. Well, the extra pet come from why are they all laid out like this?
That's a great. It looks like it was a really fun
um
Slumber party in my opinion. Uh, I'm gonna go in here and grab the bucket of blood
If I can oh nope, it's not in there. Let me just go back
Mep
I
Slumber party in the house of a god of loss that sounds pretty fun. What is this a storage room? What is that? Oh, it's mine
Uh
Yeah, be what the heck is that floating over there?
I tear a hunk of meat from the hook. This should be what I'm looking. Why is it green?
Smells kind of strange. Is this beef pork? Whatever it came from. It was huge
You should move on before I count the number of legs hanging on hooks
Yeah, that's uh, that's a lot of legs, uh
Oh
Okay, perfect. There we go blood. I don't even need that. Uh, what else did I need?
Milk, okay, I needed milk
Milk
Ooh, can I get some gloves? Is there anything? Oh spices. Okay, I'll keep mine of those
Because I probably need them. What is this bleach? Oh cooking oil
burnt hair and sulfur. Oh lovely. Uh, let's go in the fridge
This
This is the milk of the black coat. It just looks like regular cart carton of store-bought strawberry milk with a label slapped on it
Missing
I guess the cultists would have a hard time getting the real thing from Oksan now that their relationship has soured
No pun intended. Why is it spicy?
This should be good enough
Uh, uh, children's right up my spine. Am I being watched? I have everything I need. I get out. I need to get out of here fast
What the heck is that? Oh, they're bodies
Uh
Wait, what am I doing? I should go this way
Yeah, sorry I have to keep double checking the map because I get turned around really easily in these things
Hello, thank you
Wait
I'm staring at the bathroom go down the hallway turn to the side there it is
Open the damn door
Knowing that their bodies makes it less scary
It did actually
We need a gps. It's there. It's called the map. All right got that milk of the black goat
Blood and I have the fire can't we hold me make sure they're red? Okay, they're red
Oh, holy gory, I piss up with the buck pandanora
Uh
Oh
Oh, well done. Looks like you did everything perfectly impressive
Nothing to it if all the ritual
Sorry nothing to it if all the rituals are this easy. I'll have you out of here in no time
Hmm, perhaps so
Uh, I don't want to leave things as they are between us your life is your own. I'm sorry for losing my composure
Oh that I nearly forgot about that already. I'm a little surprised the literal god would bother apologizing to a human at all
Channeling strong at the end of that chant there
I've given it some thought and while you may be blasphemingly
abstinent
You're the only person in the world that can help me
You see
If you step within range of my woods any desire you have that will lead you closer to me is amplified to such an intense degree
That it's imbearable and most of the time it's lost
Anyone here anyone who has led here seeking karnor animalistic pleasures develops the sacramento chair stare
The chair becomes a cultist
If you're brought into my woods for any other reason
You don't make you don't become oh, I can't I read
Become one of my chosen thousand and your desire will make you futilely search the woods for what isn't there
You'll forget to eat and sleep and you'll search and search until you die of exhaustion become fertilizer for the woods to grow further
You're the only person to reach me without joining the cult or dropping dead
Thanks and no small part to the fact that you don't have lust to amplify
Oh, that was my my chest so my collar bones cracking
My only question is if you're not here for lost, why are you here?
I pull the receipt out of my pocket chicken curry fried chicken cheese boiga beer water ketchup soy sauce other
This is more what's in my fruit than what's in my fridge right now
I came looking for my parents
They vanished somewhere around here a year ago
This used to be a letter from them saying they were here in this house
But once I got here it turned into a blank receipt and what turned back
Excuse me
The woods have indeed toyed with your emotions to bring you here the paper is never likely never a letter from your parents
But the woods made you believe it was I'm sorry
So they're just
still gone
They were likely consumed by my woods no more than three days after they disappeared
I feel like I've been punched in the gut the dust has long settled on my parents being gone, but the grief never faded
Eat I'll give it your strength back the woods won't let you feel how tired you are
I don't feel tired at all but come to think of it
I felt like I was gonna collapse when I made it to this house
I don't think I've eaten since I got the letter either
I take a few bites
and the tears abate
There there it'll be all right star dust
Star dust how did you know my parents my parents nickname for me?
Anything that dies within my black woods becomes a part of it a part of me
Their memories of you likely live on in me wait does that mean she's dating her mom slash dad
Slash a lot of a bunch of other
dead people
It is kind of horrific
I guess that settles it my parents really are gone. That's the only way she could know that name
This isn't the kind of closure I was hoping to find here
But it came here to put an end to the disappearances and that well that's what I'll do
Wincest furry and wincest
I really like how it's like tv like we're watching a movie and it's like you can see the effects
on the screen
Um, I hope this isn't an offensive question
But all the missing people and the people that came looking for them
You
killed them all
It was never supposed to be like this
I came bearing gifts of safe childbirth for infant and mother
Hunkerlessness disease immunity
But instead my own worshipers tormented me until it broke my hearts
Now my woods are blood thirsty and I'm forced to watch a numerable die
But why how could someone do something like that? How could somebody have so much hate in their hearts?
Because it's had an eternity to accumulate
What was that it sound like something breaking downstairs it was my heart because this is sad
Yeah, definitely a crt vibe
It did have vhs tapes. I remembered that because I was pointing out the little filter
Are they coming already no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I forgot
Roxanne is just as scared as I am I need to be more careful with showing fear for her sake
It could just be the house the place is old and rotten in some places
So sometimes the house shifts on its own
I take a quick look around my room for the sturdiest thing I can find they left my bass guitar untouched
I'll check it out. It's something like it came from the kitchen
This is bad because this lags every time I do this
Okay, well it's gonna take me a century to get downstairs
I know this way I follow the green light and turn around
Oh, I didn't mean to turn around that much
Maybe I feel like I should make the window screen a little bit bigger. It's kind of small. That's fine
Please please there's a glitch what's happening here
I
The heck am I
I have to go all over there dude. I hate this
I didn't mean to go this way
My mouse is fucking
It's really like follow the green light and that shows the way just kidding. That's a lie. Wait
Yeah
It is a little bit confusing. I kind of wish it was different
If I was smart, I would memorize stuff, but that's not who I am. What?
What I went I went the wrong way. I thought it was
Sorry, I'm check I'm clearing every room to make sure you know
That's the dining room. Okay, it's through the kitchen
There's the meat I feel like there's more bodies. Can I please turn?
Doesn't it look like I just came from the kitchen though. It's so weird POV mom said clean the house
Nobody's here. I don't see anything out of the ordinary. I could have just been the house settling like I said
Oh
My god
I forgot how to
I forgot how to freaking hit her with a bass guitar and I just fucking freaked out
I didn't kill someone I just bonked her. She's fine. Her eyes are closed in a cute way
I think that hit knock them out cold
That made so much noise. I can't afford to stick around but I don't feel good about letting this maniac wake up and ambush me again
I'll tie them up somewhere. I could keep my eye on them
Why is that knife covered in blood?
What I can't for the life of me find a wound anywhere on my body
And I certainly don't feel any pain anywhere either. What?
I grab a hole of the scruff of the cultist's collar and drag them in a short distance
They feel unusually light to carry but my left arm can't produce any force
What's going on with
I guess the curse removes pain and all that stuff wow
What was that that vision no matter how much I focus I can't bring it back
Just like the fake letter I received
Are the woods concealing my injuries from me? So I can't tell when I'm about to drop dead
I sling my base over my shoulder by its strap and drag the cultist with my right arm alone
I'm sure this would be torture if I could feel pain or exhaustion
I have to go back upstairs. Oh
I hate this
Where the frick am I hello?
Oh my god
Sorry, I'm taking the long way
Making sure everything's good as one does. I know I wish I could fast travel
Is that a setting because I I I feel like that's kind of annoying
Uh
It is not oh she looks nice on the splash screen damn
I almost click clothes clothes game
Oh wait, hold on I went too far
Hey, Roxanne, do you want to oh I like how her name is to start us now. Do you want to eat her or something?
I'm back
Welcome bet. What is that?
bass guitar
Not that the dead body. I like her
I like her like surprised expect. Yeah jumps here got me good too. That's why
I like I wasn't anticipating it because I know the jump scares in the game because it literally says like
There's a setting called like worn before jump scares. So
She's ziggie stardust
Oh, they're alive actually
You took one of the thousand alive. Sorry. You took one of the thousand alive and then brought them here
this is
Very good. Actually
Now you have a blood sacrifice if we need one
What did you say?
Some of these rituals require blood or human participants
Having someone knocked out and served you on a silver platter makes things much easier
I didn't drag them up the stairs so they could be a sacrifice
I tie their wrists together behind a load bearing post in my room
Now I'm an honor god. So my moral code is completely different from that of humans, but didn't they just try to kill you?
Maybe but under that mask this could be someone else who went missing
a yoink
The mask is snug against the cultist's face but we're gonna firm yank
her
Nani oh her name is Nani
That that had to be a bit they literally did that
Nani desuka about her last name is desuka
I can't believe we did that
Uh-huh you you're that klutz from the missing person lane
You're worth a slam. We'll kill you. You'll never escape from this town alive
You're gonna oh so if somebody's uncomfortable with this I could like spray them
I did it
She's maybe I bonked you on the head a little too hard
That's a funny face. I just wanted to see what would happen
It's not that
She has this I bet like she would like be looking normal or like be like saying bad stuff right now
She has the stare her lust for the leader of the thousand buck has been amplified a thousand fold into blind fanaticism
Hey, don't try to wiggle out of that. I don't want to have to hurt you. I just need to make sure you couldn't attack me again
You think you can steal my book bash me over the head with a guitar time me up and get away with it
You're so dead
What did you expect a thank you she's long gone
It's pointless trying to talk to her if you're insisting on keeping her alive
Just do us a both a favor and keep an eye on her
If you have to look away don't turn your back on her for too long
I
Do insist on keeping her alive if she has the stare then she didn't choose this
She's just another innocent person. You got tricked into coming here
Hey, if you just stay put for now, then I can just let you go after I'm done here. Okay
Drop dead
I saw her return the mask to her first things first I need to do something about my arm
Uh, well, I guess I'm gonna stare at her while I do this. I'm like scared something's gonna happen
Place a gold skull over your face like green fire candles
In a mirror
Oh, I can raise people from the dead
All right
I
Think that was it hold on I'm just gonna stare at it. All right face a mirror green fire. Can I take that? Thank y'all
Where's a mirror I can't move
Is there a mirror?
Is there a mirror in here that I'm blind to?
I don't think so. I think I have to go to the bathroom. There's no mirror in here
To the left of her, what do you mean to the left of her?
Because these aren't these are not mirrors it's right there in between the closets
Oh, this is a mirror
No, it's not
Is it
I thought this was the wall
Yippee doodah yippee dee dee my oh my fix my arm today
Okay, come on it looks like it looks like the wall
When you when you're looking around really fast, it's the same color as the wall cat catch me
Catch me about outside. How about that cut me some slack?
All right, that should do it
I expect my arm, but I still can't tell whether I'm in pain or not. I can only hope I'm still not bleeding out
That about handles my injuries
Hey, um
What?
Your name is Nani, right? I'm gonna give you your mask back so that you can do the ritual too
I bet that lump aches, huh?
What the one you gave me
I didn't mean to hurt you. I swear you came at me. I was just offending myself. Look you're hurt. Let me help patch you up
And we'll call it even deal
Like barf me out
Here now chant bottom of the page
I know how to do it
A horna gets fog like yin and gher nor of grimm's vada
She's being simlish
better
This is gonna come back to bite you
Just wait until I break free then your toast for real
Wait, but I didn't if it wasn't on me. Oh wait, maybe did I just like throw her in front of the mirror because if it's not on me
I would have done this
Oh if the caster isn't to see oh
Yeah, I could have just done it myself for her
Doesn't make any sense. Uh anyways
form rot bloom
Okay, sorry
The ritual is required to safely pro
I didn't get to read it
Yuck. What a gruesome looking ritual. What's wrong?
Nothing just getting the creepy crawlies from this one. It looks like I've got to eat a bunch of stuff in order to make
A seed made immortal by my influence
When you die a seed will bloom
Leaving something good in the world long after you've passed away
That's kind of beautiful actually
Really you think so
Oh
I didn't get to do that
Well, the same could be said about having children
They carry on your legacy after long after you die too. And if you have a bunch of children, it's like living forever
Doesn't that sound nice too?
Hmm
Jeez all this grandkids talk you're just like my mom
I can work with that
Yo, I excuse me
Ma'am
Roxanne
Kidding kidding. I was only 60 percent serious
That's still more than half serious
But then again living forever something best done through offspring
Experiencing it yourself is
You mean like what you did to my bucky
He brought that upon himself
You cursed him he was your most devout follower and you cursed him
Wait cursed
One of my followers the leader of the thousand
So the kiss from me long ago became immortal
No matter what happens he will still exist
forever
My god, it's bucky barns
How is that a curse I could use immortality right about now wouldn't it be nice to live forever?
No
and I mean
Immortality is certainly not living forever the pain you feel after fatal wounds become permanent
lifelong agony
For instance if a human drowns they feel indescribable fear and pain for seconds
Maybe minutes at worst and then are swept away by the mercy of death. She fucked his brains out. What?
No, if I could never be immortal because like watching people you love grow up and die
Then you can never form your relationships and everything just dies around you. It's just kind of sad
It was the only good thing I think I would just like to see how humans progress in like a million years
But that's a long time but not a long time for like an immortal. So you never know
An immortal human would continue to drown thrashing and screaming soundlessly until help came if it came
So
For a moral human to be cursed with cosmic permanence
Immortality is terror beyond death
Book realize this and is tormenting me until I take it back
Wait, but I want to smooch you so I can get you smooch
How come you just don't take it back then wouldn't they let you go if you did?
If cosmic permanence was something that could be undone it wouldn't be permanent would it?
Yeah, when bucky finds you when he gets his hands on you
I didn't have to talk there
When bucky finds you what he gets his hands on you
Well, everyone you will know dialogue isn't really a hold for me people still get pets even though they know
They'll outlive them. It's so worth it
But that's like that's a that's a thing unto itself
Would you would you be like a like an omniman and just see people as pets?
But you wouldn't you wouldn't value human life anymore. You wouldn't see humans wouldn't be human to you anymore
You would lose your humanity in the process
It's a different relationship from a human to a pet
um
For pets, it's an emotional bond for humans. It's a there's many many many different bonds
I feel like you need me to be able to help fill the void that's true
I think you everybody would like I would just become a very
nihilistic
immortal
If I get if it's like omniman and I get my own wife that makes me remember happiness
Wait humans are oh my god. You guys are terrible
It's terrible
I
I'm on the other side
I think life is pointless because we die if I could live forever
There's so much that I could learn to do good. Okay, understandable
It seems like a lot of you would be immortal
Very interesting very interesting indeed
Buck is already here
The voice from the other side of my bedroom door, I didn't even hear him coming
Think of the vtubers we have in a hundred years. They would just be straight up androids walking around
There wouldn't be vt. Just be someone piloting a mech
Someone to just transport their consciousness into an android
Buck they're here
Hello in there it would appear you have my book my nani desuka and my god inside that room with you
The good news is
Number 15 you're holding all the cards. The last thing you want to do is to be holding all the cards
As long as nani is unharmed she's she's fine. I just tied her up
Is that so then it looks like we can make a deal
If you let us in we'll take nani and go
What no way once that door is open. I'm going missing for sure
Do you realize the situation you're in
No, what number 15 she be foot lettuce the first thing you'd want in your burger is she be's feet
You
We can storm in and take the book the girl and the god by force
Come on crypto so legit, bro. I just got the like this this eat the other day like in theory
And you know what that is, bro? So like I was on the market. I was like, um, I want to see my robin hood account, man
Like it's like I'll show you bro. It's like just look at my phone
This game seems familiar
Then how come you haven't done it already
You might get a lucky shot on one of us before you died
Like I assumed you did nani and if the injury was serious you'd be stuck with it for the next who knows how many years with it
All of that is too much to risk over you, you know, understandable
Right and so you'll just let me watch on while it's on out of here
We get dozens of people trapped in our woods every week. It means nothing to us if you escape
Even if I go straight to the police and tell them everything
Oh, I did not like that noise there was like all the like gun reloading stuff
in the giggle
The police are already here
Open the door and you can keep rock saying the book
You don't know how I got these scars. I don't know my voice keeps changing
And if you don't you know it will happen you have 20 seconds to make your choice
Make my choice. What do I do?
Uh, I can't do this
Well
I'm not gonna do it. I don't know what to do
You
Stop you'll hit the did I just get shot?
Did they just shoot her?
I quickly like back from the door awaiting the onslaught of cultists, but instead I hear footsteps retreating
Hey, Jackson. Thank you the super. What up? What up? I just got shot
Start us. Are you all right? I pat myself down quickly if I got hit it wasn't enough to make me lose consciousness
That'll have to do
What what gives why are they running away? Did I do something to scare them off?
They know you have to leave this room eventually so they're waiting to ambush you
Don't let your guard down. It could be anywhere
Um, I should probably do that freaking healing ritual on myself. Can I grab this? Oh, can I get a freaking knife?
Oh, you have little goat feet. Can I talk to you? No. All right, let me heal myself real quick
I
Should have some bulls drawn nearby and face the mirror does she get shot?
She she's dead, isn't she
She's straight up dead. I why am I not saying anything about that?
Use me as a human shield. Thank you. Thank you groomed by the other
I
Well, I can't heal her
Because if the intended target isn't the caster and isn't deceased
I don't know if she's deceased. Okay, that's there. Well, I'm gonna
Oh too fast
What
I got green candles. Can I not heal myself?
Okay, I guess it doesn't matter. Okay, I guess that's not the point. Um, well, I'm taking your mask because it looks cool
I have to go to the bathroom
Hello
Damn they really shot at me
Oh
Lovely bathroom we have here. What do we need to do in here? Oh, I have to perform rot bloom. How do I?
Pot of a plant which grew underwater within the black woods
Raw meat of an animal that died within the black woods petal of a flower that grew from the soil of the black woods
Show their new no let candles in the room with you face any plant in a room with your spawn partner present
And then blah blah blah. Okay
Um, then why am I in the
I can't do this
Oh eat
Okay
You know leather you seedling twos off little resistance
Watch out for jump scares. I know I'm ready. I'm ready to right click
I try to chew it, but it's hard as a rock. Something is off with the taste too
Managed to force it down whatever it was. I don't think it was poisonous, but I feel kind of sick now probably gonna move on
Um
Raw meat of an animal that died in the black woods. Is there raw meat in here?
Do I have to go get raw meat? Oh my god
Great time to freaking struggle
Oh wait, so it just says but it doesn't tell me where to go. That's so weird. All right. Well
I
Waiting to be attacked
Okay, this way open what the fuck are you doing?
Yeah
What oh, I thought I could like take him on
Okay, I guess not
Weird. Oh, there's another one. So if I died probably because there's nothing after that
Maybe avoid the room because you don't have the guitar, I guess so. Yeah
Yeah
Okay, what if I go maybe I'll go find something to defend myself can I turn?
Going the wrong way, yeah
Nope
Are you still there?
Okay, so we don't go that way back away from a threat hiding behind a door interesting. Um
Can I just leave
I
What the frick
Can I like pick up something to defend myself? Okay, so this is like if I sneak up on them. I'm a presuming
I feel like if I jump in here that something's gonna get me
Because I know he's right there because I peeked in from there nobody's there. I don't know
Oh
Ew beef tartar nice
What's an incredible smell a rich warm, sorry, I'm reading fast
Because I'm like so so like whoa right now a rich warm scent clouds my senses setting my stomach
I wasn't instantly I followed my nose and leads back to the meat could it really be to just get bad a bad first piece or something
I didn't like take another bite and a wave is said. Oh, she's getting the
Alien baby in her and it's growing and it wants more food
My appetite kicks an overdrive. I've never tasted anything like it
A third piece and a fourth and a fifth. It's like I've gone my whole life without eating until now
The second between bites feel like an attorney to withdraw eventually my hunger abates
But only after I stripped it clean to the marrow
I need to get one last ingredient a pedal pedal of a flower that grew in the blackwoods
I walk away and I land the bowl. Okay. Uh, I forget where that was
Oh, thank god. It shows me great. Um
That's right. I got to go to that bedroom
He oh nope not that way
Wait, is this the only
Oh my god, I don't like that swinging noise shut up
I guess let's keep going straight are there
I thought the flower wasn't here
No
Oh
Frick
What the heck I didn't know that could happen
Yeah, I know I'm trying to get there
Mortis no, I didn't bonk the goat yet sadly
Delicious
All right, so
They're not in there
I wonder if I open it too fast
Oh
Frick
Okay, it doesn't matter
They gave me a little
I just want a day to go. That's all I want
Okay, okay, okay, okay, it's fine
Okay
Okay, don't go freaking that way
Oh
If you see a hint
If you see a hint of skull oops, no, that's not what I meant to do
If you see a hint of skull
Go the other way
Oh
Okay, I'm fine
I think there was one over here
No, okay PTSD kicking
All right, is there gonna be one by the over here
Yeah, okay, there's one right there. I saw you you fucking bitch
Okay, we're good
It's literally just gotta go up the stairs
Is
Standing there in medicine late, is there oh, oh, don't go fucking that way Jesus fuck
Am I going okay to my brother's room
Okay, I need to be down is there is it following me no, okay
I need to go in there
Can I like trick it pretend that we just walk past each other? Oh come on you bitch sliding door
Simulator
What the frick am I supposed to do?
I can't do it unless I have the pedal
I think you need to go in there see what happens. I disagree actually with that statement
I'm gonna go to my bedroom
I think this is a safe spot so I'm gonna go in here
I talked to you. No, okay, then I'm gonna go back. She's dead taking that
Make sure I go the right way
Are you serious
Oh
Oh my god
I'll sit towards me the horror wait, what about the guys that are in there?
Huh my heart begins beating get my conscience returns to me. I'm curled up in the ground in the corner of the room
My face is wet with tears. I feel like silver hours have passed the flowers gone. Nothing remains of it my vague memory
inexplicable
Inexplicable sense of dread
They're still
All right
Don't mind me
I
Enjoy
Don't mind me at all
All right, uh, let's do this thing sure there are new no candles
Snuff
All right, we got the pot raw meat. Oh good thing. I did that in order
Uh, well, I think because it guides you it's kind of hard not to the petal of flower got that
No, the candles face any plant in a room
Okay, any plant. Well, there's a fucking
There's a plant right there. Technically. Do I face the tree?
Ha ha ha ha
Have you heard of what I have not heard of that. No
Summer nominee for number no
Uh summer I'm doing all yours. I don't want to get it through
I'm super cool
So
What
Are you doing people?
Just keep it up. I mean I'm beat them up
Walka walka. Hey, that's not the same song that I was I was thinking uh
Summer number none and you shut up the circle
Wait summer number none. Hey, I get it. I get it. Sorry. I'm tired
Well done. We're so close. I can taste it
This feeling of hope welling in my chest so unfamiliar
I he did disappoint you but we're trapped in a pretty terrible situation
I'm not sure if escape is realistic at this point
I have no many I have no idea how many of them there are and I know they're armed
I can't safely get out of this room anymore
Actually, I can I just got a creep around
The chances are that I'm going to walk around to one of their traps eventually
Even if I'm on guard every minute of every ritual left
We may yet make it out of this
I know what ritual is next
As long as Nani stays down. This will be easy. She's dead. She was shot
Nani is dead
What's up with Nani Nani disco Nani? No, she's dead
She was shot
You know how I mentioned that won't be in need of a sacrifice the time has come
Will that blood get there?
Sacrifice who Nani isn't she?
She's still okay. So she's still alive
Normally one or two fatal injuries won't be enough to kill her since she's one of a thousand but oddly enough she's slipping away
We'll have to work quickly cold blood can't be used as a sacrificed
Well, it takes a while for blood to cool
She'll be sacrificed after all that's happened to her
I can't just leave her like this, right?
Nah
I'm sacrificing her bro. Uh, there's blood right there
Oh, that's terrifying this ritual will call upon any and all firstborns. Oh firstborns. I thought this was first bones
Within the blackwoods together pretentious amount of fresh blood vile for many rituals including uprooting
If you are death shy follow these steps to avoid being targeted chant near your spawn partner
Logna you ignore lohafna after chanting immediately leave the room. Do not return early
Continued on next page
It kill me it kill me I ate someone
All right, then what is this some
Little bit of
monica in my life
Little bit of Jessica is all I need
Little bit of me makes me your man. I don't like this looks like skin
veins. It's definitely like capillaries
Well, uh
Chant near your spawn partner. So let me just face her
I just feel like that's insane
Gotta go
That sounds nice
It's going great hi
I think it's good
I kind of want a peek
Oh
I might have been a little bit too early it was quiet so I thought it was good
Frick do I got to do all that again
Yeah
All right, you can keep your hat I keep taking me the hat the hat away. All right
I just gotta say
Okay, well
I
Happens if I just stand here
Objective survive
map I gotta go to only fans. Oh wait. No, I gotta go to
The basement
Floor
That kind of scared me
What's what's the love floor I don't I don't understand that I know I took too long I was waiting to come get stuff
I
Was waiting to see what happened. All right, let's let's go yippie we gotta go down to the basement
Let's go
Do I have to be careful of there in the room
Okay
Oh yep
That baby is coming
Where's the ladder there it is
What the hey what the hell
What's happening
Uh do I do I say anything about this do I
Oh
The hot oh now it tells me nowhere within the blackwoods is safe except for the heart of the woods
The hearts will hide your scent from them to avoid firstborns. Anyway, avoid making eye contact. They will know if you saw them
Move quickly, but do not run you will attract their attention be observant. Do not look
At the next page until you've reached the hearts. Okay. Well, I'm in the hearts. This is the hearts
You see me
What
What what what
What I don't like the baby noises
Wait for the candles to go out
Do not leave the heart of the woods until the candles go on their own no matter what you see are here
Once the candles go out leave immediately return to the room where the ritual began find what they left for you and chant
Three times and the ritual
Once the candles go out leave immediately
Okay, they're left on their own
Leave immediately, okay
Are they still around
I
I'm scared. I don't know
Are they still around
I'm scared. I'm moving my microphone away from my face
Because I know I'm gonna jump and smack into it
I should have done this for the heartbeat monitor
Okay, okay, then
You
Find what they left for me by lately
Oh
Got it, but what exactly is it
Open the sack the contents are darker. Looks like if you mix another feel it smells kind of like fresh wine
I close the sack up ignoring the sight of two bright red fingers floating to the top
No time to recover from all this this excitement. I've got to end this ritual
Okay
One
Two
Three
Okay, oh so it's pretty much like doing it for me so that I don't have to like bleed out nonnie myself
Who can I put it on
How wonderful with all this fresh blood we're as good as home free
Soon we will finally leave Sacramento behind. Hopefully wherever you spend the remainder of your reality
You'll be greener pastures as well
Yeah
Wait
Oh, what?
Sorry, I swear it said start off in the beginning
Wait, what do you mean remainder of my reality?
I know it's a lot to take in but because I'm an outer god everything in this reality is my dream
Including you
Sometime after I'm uprooted. I will wake up in this reality will end
And
Nah, I'm no better or worse than any other human
Yes
And I'm part of this dream meaning I'll probably vanish too
Most likely
So
That makes me your dream girl technically
Well, that's one takeaway from the existential atom bomb. I just dropped on you, but yes, I suppose so
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh
Cool
Cool indeed, but it's about to get very very hot
Uprooting me will cause the entire black woods to burn down. So you'll need to run when can I smooch you?
What I haven't done any smooching
You know what I want I want some Nutella
I think I
Oh my god
I still don't want to stop walking over from
What's it called?
I
The Korean thing
Oh
It's Korean soup waffle
You're golden. Isn't this only chapter one? Oh my god, you're right. There's so much to do
Get up some snacks. Hmm. It's like a bueno
Ashibi is eating
Some sweet stuff from her own imagination
I guess everybody gets snacks. It's snack time
It's snack time
Really doing boomy
Oh
Big plop big stretch
Let me just hang it out
Why you snacks when I'm looking at the whole meal. Oh, you're so funny
Having posoles soon. What's posoles?
I
Don't have snacks, but this snack is right in front of you, sorry
Little joke callback
From five seconds to
This is a good idea this is this is pretty tasty
You
This morning for breakfast I made myself a banana protein shake
Boomi you can't have this you will die
And then for lunch I made that little rice bowl
With salmon and rice
I put leftover bean sprouts and Thai basil and jalapeno in it for my pho
And I have I like everything big um bagel seasoning so I have that so I just put that on there in some koopi mayo
A little bit of Thai chili sauce
And it tastes like a little um like a little little like almost like a poke bowl
I said snacks for everyone. I didn't say snacks for everyone. I said everybody get a snack and I steal a snack
What are you doing
Boomi you you don't even there's nothing for you here like you won't even like this
It's also dangerous for you to consume
That's an a oh, okay
And then I have a little stoop waffle with Nutella
I don't know what I would make for dinner though
I was digging through my cabinet and I realized I have some alfredo sauce
But I'll probably hurt my tummy, but
You know yolo
And I have spaghetti and I have frozen meatballs. So I'll probably make myself
Alfredo spaghetti with meatballs
Furry altar for Azura
This is Azura's dark form if you piss her off
Not if you take the lactate never
I have a whole box. You'll never make me take the lactate. I was dying yesterday night
Because the the the McFlurry caught up to me. I was I was suffering
You
Okay, there's literally like not even in any tunnel in here. I wonder why I saved this jar on this barely any in here
And I've been drinking water are you proud of me?
Now I'm gonna tell all over my hands
I need a napkin
I do that though, I'll be like curse you past self or yeah, thanks for my past self for having this around
Okay, I'm done snacking
Uh-uh-uh fix my pillow. How you doing?
She knocked out she didn't even like flick her ear to listen. She was she's asleep
Headphone back in
It's
Realized you've been doing this for two hours
I've only I haven't even finished the first chapter. Are we gonna endurance?
Sucker for love
Although I feel like we're towards the end of the first chapter
Just how far am I supposed to be running
I would say 60 miles just to be safe
I
What I like about this is that
It really does put into perspective like you're just a little like it doesn't cut corners with you being like a little
Human like oh like five miles away. No 60 miles like
perpetually throughout this um
Game you feel like hopeless like you're like everything's, you know, just like a little hopeless
I'm sorry smack the mic smack the mic smack my mic. Uh, wow
Wow, I turned myself down a little bit because I kept piquing the mic because my go XLR is too powerful
It's a horror. Yeah, but it's a dating horror game
I
Doing this is going to burn everything down within 60 miles
It's a small price to pay to excise the woods from your planet
Left unchecked. They will envelop the whole earth turning every human into either a cultist or fertilizer
Just
Think of it of like a widespread forest fire
And not even the worst one you've seen humanity has dealt with far larger wildfires before your towns will heal
So I just got a run for it once the fire starts
Don't stop running and leave the book behind to burn
If the thousand ever recovered it they could seed the blackwood skin and this will have all been for nothing
But what if they save the book before it turns to ash
Catch him. Let's go Pikachu
I think I'll stay to watch it burn if the blackwoods come back people will die
I probably wouldn't be able to pull this off twice
I
Suddenly raccoon city
Whatever time this world has left
I'll happily risk my life for it. Yeah, because I remember in the first game like you literally
It's like you're just you just accept the fact you're going to die and it's so it's a little terrifying how like normal
They approach it
But everything you went through it wouldn't have been easy for us
It had been from me
I
Can't let you do that after the things I've said the things I've done to you personally
You didn't do anything wrong. You didn't deserve any of this
Yeah, the emcee in the first was hundred percent more enhinged. He was just like, yeah
I wouldn't kiss you and she's just like what?
If it helps I'm not rolling over and dying
I'm going to run my heart as soon as I'm sure the buck is destroyed and you're safe
I don't know what to say
Thank you
Don't thank me yet. I've got to finish this last ritual
I can't tell if she's like her mouth is partially open or she has like a little goat buck tooth. I can't
I can't really tell. I think that's her just her mouth. Yeah, that's okay
What am I? I have to go to the fridge
If your life ship of the rocks in, Selva Eskura has soured or if you no longer
see the earth consumed by the blackwoods
This ritual is the only way to rid your reality of them for now
This ritual will cause the blackwoods to burn to ash and the hearts will return to their dormant state
This will allow you to escape from the blackwoods if you're warmed
You can never meaningfully leave the blackwoods once you've entered them
Have all the following on your person. The blood of at least 10 human-sized living things
Okay
Seed of rot bloom within you. Common flame accelerant like flour, cinnamon, cooking oil, nail polish, remover, hairspray
Go to the heart of the woods. We're facing a heart chant. Fumma na ma na mi na ma nishma na ma na. Okay
um
So I need
The blood
I have the rot bloom. I have the okay, so I just need to go to the get the cooking oil
That was downstairs because I already have that pile of blood
Thankfully, thank you miss
Nani
Do I have to
Could I just go downstairs?
Am I gonna have to freaking fight people?
Wait am I supposed to
Go to the bathroom first
I
Think they're gone, so I think they're good. I'm good. Uh, what am I doing in here? I need another seed
What's in here that I need
Oh the hairspray. Oh what I could have just get the cooking oil
Oh
It's either I get the cooking oil or the hairspray
Interest so I could have that's weird. I don't
Well, I'm assuming a lot of people go for the first one. I wonder if it makes a difference
You spin me right around baby right around
Where am I
Okay, I gotta go to the heart
Hi rena rena's just staring at me. I'd be so mad if one of those things pop out
Wait, what out to this room
Jumping up and down
Simlish is just eldritch
I didn't mean to exit
All right in chant, you know, I want to what was there a hook
I want to I want to chant at this one in particular
It actually did it you really actually did it
And so the blackwoods have been destroyed may something green and good grow from its ashes
I am so so proud of you. I can't thank you enough
It's ironic, isn't it?
The day I get my wish of never having to see a human again
It's the same day. I finally meet one worth knowing
There she goes
It's like an oven in here already
I hear frantic commotion. He must be coming
Huh?
The book is blackening in my hand
I must be engulfed in fire
The blackwoods even at the bitter end must be preventing me from feeling the flames at least that's nice
At least I don't have to feel myself burning to death
So I'm guessing the next chapters is when I get to smoocher
As long as I'm sure the book burns the very last page. This is fine
Looks like that's it. I'm still in one piece. I can run for the door
Yo
Soldier boy, tell him right now. I'm sorry. I need to put you on the ground
I can't have you on my desk. There's too much stuff up here
Now I got a little dance for y'all called the soldier boy
Yo
Did something scary happen?
What wait, what?
Huh, huh? She's so cute. Oh my god. Look how cute she is
Excuse me
Get tight another episode of sucker for love at date to die for is coming up
Oh, I can't believe I wasn't able to get the stupid book back
I guess I've got to get involved now. The book is mine
Next time on sucker for love
House of wax. I can't wait
Oh my goodness
Get true ending for chapter one and two to unlaw
Get true ending for chapter nine what?
Wait, is that look no, it's not
We just get a cliff every day. Okay, however
Uh, hold on. I'm gonna
See what happens if I open the door just to see what like if I if buck kills me
I wonder what's happens if I don't do any of that stuff
All right, that should do it
He's a rot bloom, okay
Uh
The woods fatten themselves on those dead feeds the woods the living feed the woods whose blood's the tree feeding
Um
I can't read it
Oh, okay. This is what happened before I guess it just didn't work
I'm gonna go
Is that
Okay, it's just bad and okay if I survived buck
Hit the book. Oh, no
Did I do something wrong?
But how what's the other thing that I do do I do it incorrectly?
Oops, what am I doing? Um because
If I
So I ate the pot ate the meat ate the pedal then what is this?
I did everything
Because I'm thinking this is the true ending down here
Oh, oh I could heal Nani because she's not dead. Oh my god, you're right
Okay, let me do that. Let me try that. Let me try that. Um
Is it deceased?
Is that it no very close though, okay, that's it
Like green fire candles are they green they green
Oh
She's she's still alive
The thousands tenacity is just something else. What have you done? Why did you heal her?
He knew I was here with you and fired anyway
You heard it too, right? He said to stop shooting because they'd hit the book
Stupid stupid stupid
It's just me. Are she acting different?
Thanks for bringing me back or whatever
Huh, thanks. Did she just say thank you rucksack? What's happening?
Her desire for buck was what drew her into the woods now that her desire for buck is zero
There's nothing to amplify. That's all
Really she's not one of them anymore
Hey, if I untie you you want to attack me, right?
No stardust think
Crisis of faith or not. She's still with the thousand and just tried to kill you
She literally has your blood on her hands
I slip I still had the guitar on me
Oh, it was the it was on her wrist. That's what I used to tie her up there. How's that?
She whoa, look at the art style
They look like very different art styles though. I noticed like I know that she's also like 90s art style, but
She's very I like it
Very cute very very me. I I like I like it
Tanned babe
I'm not gonna say thank you for releasing me too. You're the one you tied me up in the first place
I'm leaving. Bye
Stardust we're going to regret this
Have a little faith in me. It'll be all right. It's funny because the first thing I was like, how do I not sacrifice her?
And I didn't I forgot I can just heal her. I thought I thought I thought she was straight dead
Well, I do feel a little better that she's not in here with us anymore
Not enough being around just fine by me
Now I can smooch you
Wait
Oh
Okay, that's a part there's still so much
What am I supposed to do?
I'm assuming maybe if I eat it if I do everything that they asked
Like I ate the pot ate them eat the pedal and then she's alive. I can't do the first bones and then yeah
Okay
Let's go do it
So
Now we gotta go to the kitchen and not get stabbed
How do I get out of here? Oh, that's the door. The door looks like a freaking mirror
Bull's flowers on it
Can I turn can I turn?
Blood blood gallons of the stuff give them all that they can drink in it will never be enough
So give them blood blood
Grab a glass because there's going to be a flood
Yeah, bitch
Yeah
Bitch
Wait, no, I don't like it this way
What how am I supposed to get over there?
Please don't trap me were those cars there before
Okay, thank you at least they move around
Well, we'll see if there's one over here
There
Why was there blood the blood was there that was really weird that was a really little glitch
Oh delicious
Or go back oh hit us
Hello fuck not that way
Hello
I'm
I'm waiting for to see the white mask when they're about to grab me
All right
Where is it I'm waiting to see it. Yep motherfucker
Uh-huh I saw you
I
Nice try what about here
Ha ha bitch
Ha ha you're down there. Ha ha I'll see
Get got
Hey, what else we need? All right, so you go back upstairs to my brother's room
It's funny because like they're they're standing like normally like how they do and then
Oh, yeah
Hey, what is that what's the upside all right, it's the better
Like I'm wondering what's in this door, you know, I wonder if I do this side if I get to do a key for it
If I get to get a key for it, but if you inspect them, I don't think I want to
I don't I don't think I need to interrupt their goon sesh. Uh, that's not what I need
No candles
It's enough hello tharachnolona hope you on the yaw
So close I can taste it
Some infert well, what do I who do I?
Who are they gonna eat then?
Oh
Together
All right gotta go to the heart
I
Think I got lucky last time
And I think I was supposed to run into them at some point
Unless I'm a stupid because they
Fuck
I'm scared be shit out of me
Oh my god, dude run motherfucker run run bitch
Oh
Of course, but you know, uh, although I attract their attention
No matter what you see here
Okay, I'll I'll wait for the candles just gonna wait
Okay
Waiting for the candle it's good thing that paper doors in the way
Right behind me isn't he
Oh
Don't turn around turns around I'm the person who I run straight at an enemy in a like horror game if it's like amnesia
Ooh breaker box it doesn't do anything the things go out. Okay. I finally did
I
Back to the bedroom
I don't know if they're still around after you do it
Like I don't know if I just heard it then
I guess if you sacrifice
Her
They will come after you
Okay, find what they left for you thanks
Thank you
Thank you, you're so sweet
What
I
Was I on the wrong page I
I did it too slow. I couldn't hear over the freaking banging
If I was doing it too slow or not
Something is also in my eye. It's bothering the crap out of me
Great, I gotta do all this shit again
I
Can't all right, all right
Think that was the room they were in before let's see
I thought they weren't gonna be there
I
I feel like there's a glitch because I don't see this page until I get to the hearts which is weird
Waiting
My eye
They go out yet
It sounds like the baby from PT that's what the baby sounds like
Oh go away
No
I'm busy staring at the hearts
Black ops zombie noise maybe what the heck is down here are there more places to go
What
I
Oh my god
Because I couldn't hear like the little
Noises before so I couldn't tell what like was going on
Uh cool cool fantastic
Wait, why will I
Hold on a moment
Let me just reread all that because I I
I missed that
How wonderful with all this flesh blood flesh blood fresh blood we're as good as home free
Soon I will finally leave sacramento behind hopefully you two are every hopefully wherever you spend
Gonna be green patches as well. Yeah. Oh see they forgot there was a glitch they forgot to take her name off
There's a bug
Wait, what do you mean remainder of my reality?
I know this is a lot to take in but because I'm an outer god. Okay, so I remember this part la la la
Well permanent entities like myself and buck continue to exist between dreams, but as for non immortal. Okay, so buck would live
Oh, so
Immortality helps you from not dying when she wakes up
But where do you where do they exist then
between dreams
Stardust a cultist asking the same exact questions once before
When I gave him my answer at first he laughed as if I was joking
Shortly after he was disappointed and confused as if oh, what if buck was romancing her and then stole a smooch so he could be immortal
But then as he began to mull it over it slowly began to drive him mad until finally
He ran streaking to the woods and never saw me just kidding
Your answer was really that terrifying
I've got to know what happens to me once my reality ends
I don't know
Someone's coming is it buck did not he spill the beans and see how close we are to finishing?
I ready my bass guitar. This is it. Whatever happens. I can't fail here for my sake and rock sands. Okay
I'm ready
Where's my hand
I can't
Uh guys, I don't have a hand
Okay, I guess I'm just gonna wait
Well, I thought I have to go outside and bang him over the head
I'm so sorry
Ow, what the hell was that for oops hurry get in here
She's back why
The one time he reflexes, you know, it's funny because I saw it was her but I hit her anyways
Because I'm like, oh, it's probably gonna be Naughty coming back. Oh my god, whatever it's smacker
Because I'm leaving too and the only way I'm getting out of this he out of here is if you finish your rituals
I gotta get back to my folks and you do too. So my folks are dead
um
Actually, thanks to the thousand that's no longer possibility for yeah, see
Way to rub it in. Oh
Were they, you know, did we?
And you saved me anyways, I don't know how I could even begin to thank you
Well, you can start by helping us escape having an excaltus on our side evens odds greatly
It does
Since she has children she has the same superhuman strength as tenacity as the rep wait she has kids
What what is this kid stuff you're talking about woman, huh? What are you talking about? I do not have kids
I
What do you mean you've been buck's girlfriend all this time inside my aura of desire no less
How haven't the two of you had kids yet?
Why don't you tell me you're in the space you're the space goat with magic powers or whatever
How come instead of bring me and bucky closer you ruined everything?
Is an achievement for not bonking her
It's fine. I wanted to bunk I also like her face when you bonker
You seem to seem pretty close before he um shot you
Well, I mean I guess to be close if I ever got to see him or have any time alone together
I mean that was what I thought of all this was going to be
He told me that the black goat of the woods was like some goddess of love or lust or whatever
So I was like
Oh, like OMG, that's totally hot. Let's summer right now
But like as soon as we did he like stopped talking to me
Between you and all the other girls that wander in a town. It's like I'm invisible or whatever
I said explains why not he thought I was here for a buck when we ran into each other
For a second back there when I thought he realized how much I meant to him
Back when he said that you can keep the book and the god if he just got me back
But I guess I'm like
Hey, don't get yourself down. There's plenty of other violent cult leaders out there. I'm sure you'll find the right one for you
Thanks, but I think I'm swearing off skulls and robes for a while after we do these rituals that is
Is
Have a bow on it
Flower that's cute. Here's everything you need for the next one. Save you the trip. Oh, thank god
Really to think she was returning just to help me
So after this reality will end eventually
Yes
I'm part of this dream meaning I'll probably vanish too
Most likely
So that makes me your dream girl
Well, that's one tick. Oh, here he did this. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Oh, cool
Cool indeed, but it's about to get very very very hot
I'm seeing if there's any do stuff
You're never gonna make it out anyways the thousand are ready to die for buck the mob us as soon as this place starts burning
Here if you take my old robes and mask you can like slip right past them
I'll stay behind and make sure the book burns. Oh, so she sacrifices herself for us
And she take your scrunchie back
Oh
I wish I saved you at the beginning
You're a real one girly pop a boop your nose boop
But what about you won't they kill you if they see you without your cult stuff?
As if they know my face if they see me running away, they'll let me go
Here try this on
I slip on the rose and tuck my head into the skulls goat skull mask if it's snugly
It fits. Do you know what that means? It means you sit
The disguise will work
Well, yeah, but more importantly it means are the same size
I regret but no, I don't regret bonking her the face was cute
Can I like totally raid your closet on my way out because like I didn't want to say this while we were trying to kill each other
Anything, but I love your pastel goth look stuff. Yeah. Oh
Yeah, take whatever you want. It's all burning to the ground anyways
But so weird though like she can't remember anything
Is like is that her stuff like I don't know if this is really her house
Awesome
Stardust no
We're so close to escaping you can't throw it all away now by trusting her if the book doesn't burn all this will be for nothing
If you trust her and then she hands the book over to the thousand both of us are going to pay for it
She already switched sides once today
I got us this far didn't I?
You don't let you down now
But she
Uh
All right, I I just want this so badly. I don't know if I have any hearts left to break
Oh, look at all our broken hearts. Oh
Come on, let's head on down to the root room and finish this
Okay
Yeah
Turn so slowly. Oh, look at you. You look so cute when I spit
They're gonna be dudes I can't remember if there are dudes down here
Oh
Wait, you want to end up with nani? No, I'm good. I want to end up with a goat mama. I still want her
I
Blood rop loom accelerant, but uh
You actually did it you really actually did it
And so the blackwoods have been destroyed blah blah blah blah
There she goes like an oven in here
Toss me the book
Look down at the purple ritual book hearing rock stands where he's echo one more time through my head. I know what I'm doing
ha ha
Here, sorry
Here ha ha ha. I didn't imagine that I ending with me willing hitting the book over to you
Oh my god, right? Totally not what I expected at all
You know buck really wants this book and now that the woods are all burning down. He'd probably give anything to have it back
If we went back to the thousand together we could just ask for anything
I'm sure he'd let you join
I can squirt her if I want
And now that me and buck are through I totally go out with you
Oh, I can't date her
Nani we have to burn the book
You sure one last chance to go with me
Nani
kidding kidding. I was just kidding. James mostly
You want to like you want to just like, you know, so sorry you want to like, you know
Something we can you know hit up that other, you know the goat girlie, you know
She takes a long look at the book before tossing into the fire
Hey, this is like so embarrassing to say, but I think we would have been besties. The things have been different or whatever
You know, like besties that like kiss a lot. You're so cute
See ya
Her smile is really pretty. I wish we could have met somewhere else too
Time to go. Hopefully the sky is enough to escape
Oh, I actually have to escape
Oh
My god
Nani is that you
Shoot, I wasn't expecting to have to talk my way. Why do they look so weirdly drawn?
Yeah, um totally
It is her. What are you still doing in here? The place is coming down. Do I really have all of them fooled?
Damn it that outsider must have completed the upper ritual if you rush her you might be able to save the book
Right
There's no way the book is burned all the way yet. I need to buy nani's more time
Wait, I'll like totally get the book myself or whatever
Really?
Nani you're amazing
You're a true believer
I can't believe you sacrifice yourself for all of us. Come on guys. Let's get out of here. Right
Morons, okay, cool
Let's just go I wonder if they'll be fire. I have to dodge
What
Where am I going
There's like water right there. I can just probably jump in the water. Oh
Hey, what does that say?
Ah
No, wait, go back. It doesn't matter just get the fuck out
I
Other paper towels just chill in there
Ah
The handle is probably so hot
I made it I survived the night just kidding buck is probably gonna shoot me. Oh shit
I've got a lot to a to go for I'm clear of the wildfire, but I'm ahead of it for the moment
Better be sure that this is the robin mask. I don't want to be mistaken for a cultist on some home free
I lower my mask only as I watch my childhood home burn to the ground
Is that why they tanned nani?
I just realized that because I'm like, wouldn't they be able to tell them apart with like the hair and stuff?
Or maybe they put the wood the foot on
The house crackles out as the wind foundation splinters
Large sections of the house begin coming down in cinders bring any cultists unfortunate to have been trapped underneath
This should be the end of the experiences. Wait, what's that? Is that freaking buck?
Oh my god
No, you bitch
Wait, did she did she wait she's like I ended up not giving the book back
Wait, wait, was that her? Was that nani's boy? I don't know
Oh nani has left a thousand I wonder if I can like recruit people true and let's go
Yeah, the second and third chapters are already out
Oh, hold on. I want to see I don't know if I have it it in me because I'm in a lot of pain
Um, yeah, I'm gonna end it here
It is really cute. I really like it
All uh, don't worry after my fps week next week. I'll bring I'll bring
I'll put suckers for love sucker for love back on there
I want to I want to see what the checkpoints look like
Okay, then there's there's it's always two choices
Cool cool cool looking forward to the next chapter. Yeah, oh everything's gone
Everything's gone
Oh
I have merch
Use code
Shabby I miss my arm with the hurts shabby for 10 off. He-he
But I hope you guys enjoy we're gonna find something to raid
That was really fun actually
I was I was spookier than I thought it would be but it's fitting for the summer we
Tomorrow what do we got going on tomorrow?
What do we got going on tomorrow?
We got the hand cam you got two hand cams back to back. So tomorrow at 6 p.m
shop be there be square
We go
Hand cam stream or I'm gonna read you tarot and make spell jars the tarot will be
Uh, I'm I'm probably gonna do like five bucks and I'll read it for you
um
Just because it can be
Sometimes people just kind of overwhelm me with requests and questions. So if you really want it
Bring your lunch money. Bring your five dollar and I'll I'll read your tarot
Hey, it's better than some like some lady at a rent fair that asks for 40 bucks. Okay
All right, that happened to me once I went to a rent fair and I was like, you know
I've never gotten like a reading from someone else. So let me get a reading from someone else. I sat there
You know dressed up real cute in my little fairy costume because of course I dressed up
And
She's like that'll be 40 dollars and I'm like what?
Jesus christ, all right
and um
Gavor it and then she pulls cards in mind you again. I can read cards. She's like
Someone's recently passed away and like really typical stuff
Someone's recently passed away in your life and they're reaching out to you from the other side
Is this correct and I'm like, no
No one
Not going in my immediate family has died
My family is fine
I'm like my cat died three years ago. She's like it's that and I'm like, bitch. Don't even
Don't even don't even with me lady
And then I'm just like I'm then I'm looking at the cards and I'm like
I'm like I just wanted a general reading and so like while she's talking
I'm just zoning out and I'm just looking at the cards that she pulled and then I'm looking to myself and I'm like
None of this means shit. I just wasted 40 bucks. I should probably just leave
So she's like, thank you. And if you feel want to leave a tip and I'm just like, yeah, and then I just walked away
I was like, no
I also make a spell jar. I have stuff to make spell jars. I already have I've had to make stuff to make spell jars
I'll do um some sort of like
relaxation
spell jar
Probably for us. I'm like calming
like good vibe spell jar
I'm feeling that
But uh, I'm gonna I need to get my my nails done tomorrow
I'm gonna get my nails. I think I'm gonna do black
I think I'm gonna do black I might get like I'm tempted to get like the stiletto like super sharp pointy nails
But I don't think I will. I think I'll just get like
Coffin perhaps I think coffin shaped nails would be cute
It's a little early
But you know, I'll be honest with you
I really don't like red nail polish on me because because like red's just not my color. It just clashes with my skin tone
um
I'll tell you that
Just like unless it's a if it's a deep red it looks good if it's like maroon, then it looks fine
but if it's like a bright red
like my
normal like my my
Model's nails it kind of looks funny
Uh, but yeah, so that'll be fun tomorrow. Let's see
Oh
Conn is playing black myth wukong. I'm debating whether or not to get black myth wukong
I'm gonna I'm gonna um
It means doing a t-shirt painting stream, which looks really cool. So I'm just gonna I'm being held at gunpoint by my mom
What and I took up for I we we we I took uh, I took
I took up an hour of her normal slot. So I'll just send send it her way. Send you guys her way. That's funny as hell
Uh
Hold on I can't really see the chat that well my resize stuff
And this chat looks is really dumb to read what FPS will I play next week?
I'll have you you can guess
I
Would you like to guess
You can guess
No, I'm not playing fear. I'm sorry titanfall too, baby
We playing titanfall
We're playing titanfall, baby
We got I'm not playing overwatch. I'm playing overwatch one. Yes. Uh, yeah, I'm playing the campaign
um
No, we're not I'm not playing team fortress too
Yes, we are planning halo, but we have another collab we're doing
Um
So I'll tell you I'll tell you what I what we're doing next week
In a week I've been in the mood for I was gonna do destiny, but I'm like now I won't put people through that
Because I would just be playing multiplayer. I would just really just playing the crucible the entire time
Whatever the frick it's called now
Where's the schedule
So you guys get a little no left for dead. I'm not playing left for dead
Um
So we got
I'll tell you I'll tell you the schedule
So monday
I'm gonna be playing gargic phone with you guys if you're a member if you're a member and you want to play gargic phone with me
Um, and we'll like how play people swap out and stuff
Then I think that'd be fun
You know
You know I wanted
Get in the robot
League arc was she being I I don't know how to play league
I've never played league in my entire life and I will never touch league in my entire life
No, thanks. Um
Uh the and that's at 6 p.m. Because
Stroni likes to take up the entire day on monday, although it's only me and her streaming
We have we're hanging out. Uh, yeah, she has
She's with like a personality stream and then a member walked along and then I think I might do
A member thing and then till like maybe like 11 p.m. Play like elden ring
Um
I don't know or whatever you guys want me to play. Um after the member stream
I'll probably do some sort of gorilla if I feel like it if I'm up for it
Uh tuesday 4 p.m. Titanfall 2
Um
But it's her birthday
It
That's trust me for Azura's birthday. She doesn't want to play league with me
I could I could assure you of that
um
Wednesday 28th
Do maternal baby you playing do maternal I saw it was on sale
This is what it was. I was really looking. I'm like, what should I do next week?
Because normally I have my schedule done by wednesday so so my um manager can make all my thumbnails
And so I saw it was on sale for like seven bucks
And I'm like
Yeah, yeah, we're doing that. Yeah, we're playing doom eternal
And I'll be honest with you. I've never touched a doom game in my life either. This will be my doom virginity being taken
I've never played the original dooms. I want to play the original dooms. Um
But I think I would just start off with something like
Hmm
Although what year did doom eternal come out like I don't know how many years ago
But then like then I'll go play maybe I'll have like a retro week. Well, I'll play like a bunch of retro games
um
And then so that'll doom eternal be wednesday 4 p.m
Thursday
6 p.m. Don't worry emmy's not streaming in that slot. She's doing something else that day at a different time
Uh, she has some sort of collab with people. I'm not going to spoil it though because that's her schedule that she will talk about
um
Thursday
29th 6 p.m
fallout new vegas, baby
I've never played a fallout game
I've never played a fallout game in my life. It looks like what's that like that free switch game fallout shelter
Um
I also wanted to play doom eternal because that doom the dark ages looked so good to me when I saw the trailer
uh
Lots of bangers indeed. So fallout new vegas, uh
And then friday, I already had planned something with niana banana
We're gonna do two cat girls bully you asmr and i'm gonna kind of teach you how to do asmr. I'll try to do it
better
than what I did
for
Potas parasi and actually try to teach niana stuff
um
Hopefully new vegas doesn't crap itself. Perhaps. I have backups just in case
saturday
31st
4 p.m
Borderlands we're playing borderlands. It's funny. I've never played borderlands
And mind you I've had
fallout new vegas and borderlands on my
On my pc for years and I've never touched them
Uh doom eternal I just bought today titan fall. I've had for I actually um played through uh recently
So I shouldn't be too dog shit at it
Um, this is all preparation for october 26 when although it's you know
Over a month away
A little over a month away for black ops 6. Uh, I haven't played the last I I usually only I only
Really have played call of duty more to warfare. I haven't played any of the black ops games
I remember watching my dad play a lot of black ops and like zombies and stuff with his friends
But I wasn't really allowed to play fps shooters until I was able to be smart enough to play them in secret
Um, because my dad said they were too violent for me
He wasn't wrong
I didn't yeah, I didn't I didn't touch like cs go until I was like 16
um
A borderlands one I do have borderlands two if you guys have a preference
Been feeling a sheep. Don't say that don't that's not nice. Um
I have borderlands one and two so if you have a preference
probably two
one is the og
For okay, everybody's really saying two one is out. Okay, then I'll I'll change it to borderlands two then
Uh, let me do that right now
borderlands two
I think do I have like the game of the year edition or something? Let me look
Oh, no, I have the game of the year edition enhanced for the regular version for the first one
All right, we'll do borderlands two
Especially because the movie just came out
Excuse me, but yeah
That's that
Borderlands three I never bought borderlands three so
I never I never never ended up buying it. Um, all right, so I'll send you guys on over to emmy
Uh, I heard the movie. I heard the movie sucks too. Yeah, that's why I'm like, you know what?
Let me play the game so I can if I ever like
See the movie when it comes out on DVD and I told they watch it in a member's watch along
If like I can be angry like everybody else
That movie sure does exist. Just kidding. No, I never do make us do that in a watch home. Um
But yeah, sucker for love is really good. I hope you guys enjoyed
Uh, you can see madam the doom armor
We'll see how bad I am in fps is
Uh, I used to be pretty nasty at them. I have I've been kind of out of touch
I haven't played an fps since I played valorant with nori
Last october
I was a long time ago. That was the first time me and nori ever hung out and the first thing we did we played valorant together
And we were just toxic the entire time
um
I actually used to like valo. I used to like valo a lot
Um, because it reminded me so much of csgo
and I liked again, I liked the
What like kind of sweatiness of csgo
But not as sweaty as like see like rainbow six siege because I don't like rainbow six
I'll I'll never I'll never play siege. I played that once with like
uh prominent
youtuber friend of mine
and
The mind you this was this was years and years and years ago. This was like
Yeah, this was years ago and they were so toxic. I never touched the game again
I was like, I do I never want to play if people are like this. This is horrible
Um valorant is bad as like I like valorant. I like casual valorant casual games. That's fine casual cs. That was fine to me
um
Yeah, it really sucked because I like
I like I like it's really hard being told that you're so dog shit at a game when you just started
And this person is streaming to a lot of people
And they're just shitting on you and I'm like, ah, well one I've never talked to you again because you're a horrible human being too
I'm never playing this game again. Thanks for ruining it for me
um
But it's funny because I want I used to want to be a competitive cs player
Like I really wanted to be a competitive csgo player. I wanted to be the first
POC female competitive cs but that probably that title is long gone. Um, but it was it was a goal of mine
I was never that good by the way
Never like I was never
I couldn't get past like
gold
valorant
I was never like platinum diamond. Whatever the fuck. No
Same with same with apex
All my homies hate apex by the way
Um, I'm never I'm not really good if I used to play fighting games
Like when my dad would bring me to like an arcade, but otherwise I never like played like
Fightems fighting games
I because I would just I'm not like
When it when it comes to fighting games, I'm not super smart about them. I just button mash
like
even with like
Yeah, even with I'm just like so annoying to play with for a fighting game because I just like
Exploit a weakness within the fighting or like just one move and I'll just spam it like I do Eldenry
Like so when I play like super smash bros
I would just I would play. What was her name? She was from
She was from fire emblem
the corn
I
Yeah, it was corn
I would just spam the dragon
constantly
just
Whatever just smacking
Yeah, I just spam and so a people of commentators doing a fun event with creators getting taught by professionals. That would be so cool
Guys, I want to be in some sort of like
um
Like tourney or like I think maybe that'll be one of my goals like I get like I'm in some sort of tournament
Honestly a feeler was in the that um
The mario kart tournament. I would have won
I would have won bro. I am nasty at mario kart
nasty
You can ask
Niana when we stream together
I played with her and my pl and a bunch of other girls and they were so sick of me because I kept winning every
Re-king game and I started throwing because I felt bad
So I just started throwing because I felt bad
I
Don't worry. You'll see you'll see my mario kart skills
Uh, but that'd be cool. That'd be cool. I don't know if I could ever do a turn like again. I can't have
Males in it disgusting hook to it. We don't want males right here. I don't need males near me. No, thank you. I am good
I am good
You can't see I'm I'm holding my hands up like I'm the like the
Uh, I'm gonna do it to him dude who's standing on the sidewalk with pink shirt. That's how I'm staying. I'm sitting right now
My turn mario carvers chat
I'm not but the funny thing was when we started introducing chat to because we started like we play with niana's viewers
Then I started getting like I was like coming in third and I was like dammit because these like those people that were like
No, life in it
Males yeah
No males allowed
disgusting
How did it flush the toilet after taking a shit?
Where it was one of us
A bit of topic but if a vtuber streamer suggests some sort of event competition
Are we allowed to suggest to the viewer livers, especially if it looks like something one of them? Of course
Of course you can um, but again, we have to be invited to those things
Like we can't just be like yeah, we're in like
People usually will reach out to our management team
And be like hey, we would like if your talents participated in this this and this whether it be like
a con an event
Uh tournament vice versa
um
So, yeah
Is our treat just gets the amount of r34 search what?
I'm actually really good at number guessing, but yeah, so and also like probably have to get perms for that sort of stuff
Managers talking to managers face to face shit. Yeah, but it's it's also just like, you know nuance
Vtuber community stuff
I'm I'm discovering this um
But yeah, let me
Arm, I just want to cut my arm off and just throw it across the room and just like pop on the new bionic arm
And you can call me johnny silverhand
Um
Yeah fans getting people aware that's about it. Yeah, but you also don't want like people like fans like crying about stuff and like being like hey
Hey
Can they join this because people like they'll just like hate us
By extent of you or like hate the fans and that's whatever don't worry about it
Don't worry about it cyber slime bunny girl dominatrix. I accidentally ripped a hole right in the front of my shorts that I'm wearing
I just have a whole
How did this even happen?
You
Well, I
Remember the one I tweeted earlier or what I tweeted
It's on the front side. Remember what I tweeted about having buns of steel
So I've had these shorts since I was like 15
And I think the friction
from the front just
Destroyed them and now there's a whole
Little for for easy access if you will
And you're 56 now exactly I've had these for a very long time and I've maintained my figure in the process
Bit of a topic but I feel like you imitate doki bird's voice
I probably could because one time I was watching a lot of her streams
And then I went on to stream and then I realized I was talking like her
Well, like guys and she's like a little bit deeper and she has like a little bit in the back of her throat
and she kind of talks like
Hey guys, it's me doki bird
I can't do her laugh if I listen to her I could do it. Hold on. Let me listen to her
I'm getting distracted by talking. It's fine. No, I'm now I'm determined
Now I'm determined I will learn I will just I need I need a demo reel of me doing just a bunch of voices
Okay doki bird clips
What is this star wars outlaws hello, what is this?
I want like I need like a good new multiplayer fps game. That's why I'm kind of interested in the new black ops game. All right, hold on
And then when you die you can call me in
I
Believe in you
You tag me in when you're fucking dead she has like a californian accent
I'm watching a clip or she it's called doki one, but at what cost
Me in the tutorial this game was like
Yeah
He actually knows how to play
I like how no I like how the other team they're like actually trying how to get there
Ah
Me try to find another one
Can I please get some doki bird clips? I'm just staring here. You guys can't hear
Whoa
That's a big boy
big boy
Look at him
Oh, this one she's playing black math buccane. Oh, this is from freaking dang. This is from six hours ago. She's already clipped
Doki trying to talk dirty hold on what I can't open it unless
If I caress it enough
If I say something nice to it
it'll be like
Hey there pretty girl
Have I told you the most beautiful door out there?
If I caress it enough it'll be open
Negative risk
We want to spread your hinges for me. Sorry. I'm right. That's it's literally called doki trying to talk dirty
Can you imitate harem's voice? Hi, I'm harem
I
It's funny because they put like the
The like careless whisper saxophone behind her trying to be that now don't give her just don't give her just funny
I like she has a very unique voice very very distinct and unique voice
I wish I had a very unique and distinct voice
I feel like my voice is kind of like a normal deeper register but a lot of people like I've listened to people sound like me
constantly
Um, so it's very interesting
I like how I 30 minutes ago. I said I was gonna read it. I mean this always happens
People are leaving because I said I was gonna end and now I'm a two view
I don't know how to feel about that. We can go for another 30 minutes
Let me see
Oh
Have you seen evil? I have not seen evil
I almost clicked go live. What is wrong with me? Can I do can I stream twice the same?
I don't know how I did that last time members got a little treat there
Uh
Oh
All right, let me just let me just stream and read to me
All right guys, it's been super cool. I'll see you guys later
Oh my god, that was terrible. Oh, yeah, why would I wouldn't I wasn't gonna cut the member of odd down
I'm working on it. I'm working on the I'm working on the doki impression
She like laughs like very like she's very compressed her laugh gets compressed a lot
And I have to like go lean away from the mic to do it
All right
I don't want you gone don't say that don't say it girl liar
Stop lying to me. Yeah, I'm gonna put some ice on it. I don't know what the inflammation is
Um, take that take an Abba profit
Take take some amoxicum
Take some GABA patent that sounds terrible sound the people who don't know what those drugs are probably like, oh my god
She's a great. No, it's just what I take for my pain my nerve pain my muscle pain
My pain pain
Life is pain
That's a quote from somewhere
Did I quote spider-man again I keep quoting spider in
Pretty sure I've been quoting like green goblin
Anyways, I'll see you. Bye